hallo mein name ist yukon herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
akinator ich habe das ganze schon circa
zweieinhalb monate nicht mehr
hochgeladen
ich bin trotzdem immer noch hier bei den
letzten zehn spielen ich hab euch nicht
mal gesagt dass er nicht spielen sollte
oder ihnen was man mir einreichen soll
da ich dieses spiel so lange nicht mehr
gespielt habe würde ich sagen ich
versuche erst mal mich selbst zu finden
um mal zu schauen ob ich es noch kann ja
meine figur wurde durch youtube die
haben eine figur slams player sie hat
nichts mit einem schwein zu tun sie ja
ich hab allure hat deine figur einen
langen schwanz alles klar ja auf jeden
fall ist mit muskelkraft
da weiß er direkt beim start vettel ja
natürlich ist meine figur die website
hat kein bisschen dazu gelernt hat deine
figur langen schwanz ja dann ist es
eigentlich schon klar dass es lukas ist
deine figur kräftig druck auf ja hat
eine figur bei minecraft kaputt gemacht
wahrscheinlich gibt es noch ein
minecraft cap das projekt oder ja da
habe ich mitgemacht ich ja ich kann so
einen backflip ist deine nein ich bin
kein haustier von einem youtuber und das
ging aber schon mal besser wir haben
leute damals immer screenshots geschickt
zu erste frage ist deine figur crafter
alles klar alles klar
als klaus lage ja das bin ich und ich
wurde über eine halbe million
das müsste eigentlich feiern mensch
freunde ich hätte es echt nicht gedacht
zuletzt gespielt um 20 uhr das war vor
einer minute auf mutter ford blöcke des
dass das war ja ok jetzt ist gerade 20
und 35 aber warum seid ihr so fucking
aktiv ich habe dass ich habe ehrlich
gesagt akinator solange nicht
hochgeladen weil jeder youtuber
irgendwie akinator clan hat und ich
dachte okay wenn es jeder mag dann ist
es ja brauche ich nicht auch noch machen
und jetzt nach oben
es findet ihr sohn eis an diesem
beispiel während ich jetzt einfach mal
bei der nächsten runde irgendwelche
wirren antworten angeben möchte ich euch
ganz kurz eine sache sagen ich drücke
beispielsweise einfach mal
und dann wahrscheinlich nicht und dann
beispielsweise mal ja und dann nochmal
ja nochmal ja ich möchte mit euch über
etwas reden und zwar habe ich über so
ein thema mit euch schon damals mal
geredet ich habe euch damals mann in dem
video gefragt das verlange ich euch
beispielsweise mal hier da habe ich euch
gefragt bezüglich ob ich mit einem
unternehmen ein 360° video aufnehmen
soll das ganze wäre dann allerdings
werbevideo und es wäre halt eine
kooperation mit einem unternehmen und
alle von euch meinten luca wenn du
wirklich bock auf solche sachen hass und
wenn es wirklich nicht gestellt
rüberkommt macht von mir aus alles das
meinte die mehrheit in den kommentaren
nach dem motto luca wenn du bock drauf
hast und wenn du dich nicht verstellt
uns irgendeinen scheiß produkt andré
sowie die ganzen beauty tanten ist es in
ordnung an alle die jetzt gehofft haben
dass in 360 grad video ein kluger typ
der immer zufällig antwortet keinen sinn
ich hab doch sogar teilweise zehn
hintereinander jahr gedrückt das 360°
video wird leider erst mal in naher
zukunft nicht stattfinden
das mache ich jetzt irgendwie doch nicht
ein paar sekunden später das kann nicht
warten schon wieder ein typ der immer
zockt allerdings ist jetzt eine andere
sache aufgekommen und zwar wurde ich
angefragt von google ob ich nicht lust
hätte drei games von denen zu zocken
dies hat im google places tor gibt als
ob schon wieder man ihr müsst euch quasi
vorstellen google hat einfach gesagt ja
wir haben ja beide play games festival
und wir haben hier wirklich 3 muss ich
wirklich sagen die spiele sind echt nice
ja mir drei spieler hätten boxe geben
spiel ein video zu machen sowie das
sonst auch immer machst nur das ist halt
eine kooperation mit google ist und ich
halte in dem video so ein bisschen
darüber was das google play games
festival eigentlich ist und warum ich
das spiel gar zocker nicht dass jetzt
denkt dass das ein ekliges game ist was
irgendwie so ein browserspiel und mitra
grafik und ich kann nichts machen ich
weiß nicht ob ich es verraten darf als
ich es nicht verraten darf und google
dass sie tut es mir leid vielleicht
werde ich jetzt gefeuert von youtube
oder so ein spiel von den weg bin ich
bitte auf eine pornodarstellerin
gekommen ein spiel von den drei spielen
es beispielsweise addario also ein spiel
was ich eh schon locker zehn zwanzig mal
hochgeladen habe ich werde jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht merken
die videos in kooperation mit google
sind es wird halt nur immer oben in der
ecke werbevideo stehen hier so circa
irgendwo dann in der ecke weil es
einfach eine rechtliche sache ist dass
dementsprechend machen muss ich wollte
euch nur sagen oder beziehungsweise
frage ob es euch in ordnung es ist
hinter drei spiele bei denen ich
unterstützt werde das ganze aufzunehmen
es ist eine kooperation mit google
es sind wirklich geile spiele also keine
angst und es in sachen die ich früher
oder später auf einem kanal gemacht
hätte also ich finds halt wichtig mit
euch dazu kommunizieren damit wir das
ganze transparent halten und ich nicht
nach jetzt ein video hochladen da
einfach steht dann produktplatzierungen
ich hab mich darüber geredet wie so ich
mache oder eine ahnung ich sehe euch als
freunde an deswegen will ich euch das
ein typ der immer zockt etwas anderes
haben vor ein paar tagen kam er die
nintendogs folge raus und da meinten
viele junge ein neues hündchen ist das
schon beim akinator das ist immer so
wenn ich ihnen gegeben irgendwas benenne
direkt kommt in den kommentaren
ich frage gar nicht nach macchiato ist
es eh schon da jetzt mal das kleine
hündchen und zwar meine figur ist keine
frau sie ist durch youtube berühmt
gewohnt deine figur in kraft das zimmer
und eine figur mit kultcharakter ja
meine figur ist keine flasche
ja gut sie hat blue als freund mein
kleiner pudel wirbt nicht für schweizer
produkte ja die über deine nase nein sie
ist kein mensch ja die figur welt nein
ich habe diese figuren noch nicht als
plüschtier ich habe etwas mit der figur
zu tun ja sie es auf meinem kann ich war
gerade angerufen um viertel vor
ich nehme gerade noch auf ob es in einer
minute schaffe da hinzukommen
wir wissen ziemlich recht eng gut ich
war wohl zum essen champions league
schon verabredet und es ist gerade 20 43
wolfsburg spielt gerade das gerade
dienstag ich bin kein wolfsburg fällen
aber hat er nicht wie gut dass mit dem
tempo zu tun ja sieht man eine figur vor
der cam
nein mein hund heißt doch nicht nintendo
kven die figur es kein pokemon ja sie
ist weiblich sie ist kein arzt ja sie
hat in einem von mirja siehst dich mit
bekanntgeworden ein sich nicht alle 15
sie hat nichts mit übernatürlichen zu
tun die alle etwas mit dem sender zu tun
sie hatten nicht besonders lang getan
sie ist kein flaschen greifen ich denke
anfang eingereicht von balu alles klar
wir finden wohl irgendwie das kleine
pudel hündchen noch nicht deswegen sage
ich jetzt mal das ist bei lugano wurde
160000 mal gespielt muss ich da noch was
zu sagen ich glaube ich muss da nichts
mehr zu sagen deswegen beende ich jetzt
das video an dieser stelle ich habe ja
einen großen teil des videos damit
verbracht über die kommenden drei gaming
videos im rahmen des google play games
festival ich werde übrigens für das
ankündigen hier gerade nicht bezahlt mit
milliarden von euros und ich mache das
nur weil ich mit euch da gerne darüber
reden möchten euch nach eurer meinung
fragen möchten wenn ihr alle sagt luca
das ist total kacke
dann ist mache ich nicht ich weiß nicht
ob ihr euch freut weil ich wieder nur
folge die nato aufgenommen oder ob ihr
euch denkt jahre lass es doch besser
einfach sein
zeigt mir eure meinungen
und bewertet das video wenn es euch
gefallen hat oder bewertet es nach unten
wenn es euch nicht gefallen hat es ist
eine komplette normale meinung und ich
komplett zu spät
ich muss los